después de más de un año de pandemia
brasil sigue registrando cifras inéditas
este martes tuvo el día más mortal por
kobe 19 con 3 mil 780 fallecidos en 24
horas una situación de salud crítica que
llega a lo económico con cada vez más
personas con dificultades para comer
esposo mire esa situación si no fuera
por la iglesia repartiendo esta comida
no sé dónde comería donde no tengo
dinero
el colapso también llega a chile con
hospitales desbordados como en
valparaíso en el hospital van buren
tuvieron que recurrir a dos morgues
móviles y eso pese a que la práctica
totalidad del país está confinada y ya
hay más del 35 por ciento de los
chilenos vacunados que da la sensación
de que
como se encontró que había un éxito muy
importante en la campaña alguna acción
elegido se conoció en argentina para
evitar el colapso de sus vecinos este
martes se cerraron fronteras terrestres
el día en el que se superaron los 14 mil
casos en 24 horas una cifra no vista
desde octubre además siguen restringidos
los vuelos internacionales con méxico
chile y brasil
el repunte llega a ecuador con unidades
de cuidados intensivos saturadas y con
quito y guayaquil aplicando
restricciones esta última tendrá un
horario elaborada hasta las 4 de la
tarde mientras que la capital restringe
la movilidad desde las 10 de la noche a
las 6 de la mañana será una semana santa
diferente en el transcurso de estos días
tenemos una alta ocupación en las camas
del sistema hospitalario de quito pese a
que los contagios también suben en
colombia' con casi 8000 casos en 24
horas la cifra del día es que se
alcanzaron los 2 millones de dosis
administradas un número que esperan que
suba a 3 millones para el 17 de abril